welcome to this video playing out
something from Sweden can i play
something else here I'm not a six all
the time okay let's let's do this the
heinous damn beds or Schliemann gambit
always a bit tricky the names yeah
Bishop see sixes is seldom plate for no
particular reason I think okay if I take
and now Queen t4s the support system
moves in quickly for Queen each fiber
can play g6 this shouldn't be a big
problem yeah okay let's do that check
you know this is not working yeah I have
the rook protected check okay okay this
is just just excellent for black unless
I'm blundering something on I don't
think so yeah it's just this pieces are
all active now p he got all the porns
but I have all the activity so on I can
quickly again again again threads going
I see three is especially weird I mean
queen bee three so just one problem okay
but let's let your threaten inmate okay
checkmate yeah no no no idea what he was
doing here probably am probably he just
overlooked beforehand that I have the
route protected yeah this is already a
very very bad for white tank is this is
just probably just losing he only has
two pawns if i'm not mistaken there are
two pawns and i have two did they're
taking chances going here this is not
playing so black is just winning so my
favorite quick game
but yeah thanks for watching anyway